hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video auf
einem kanal viele denken dass
krankhafter beziehungsweise max und ich
zusammen sind ist auch eigentlich ja wir
haben also ein video dazu hochgeladen
allerdings habe ich eine neue freundin
und zwar ist es diese hier mit der habe
ich auch schon zwei videos hochgeladen
wir sind noch immer auf einem blind date
mit der frau namens erian das ist ihr
haus sie erwartet uns wir dürfen jetzt
eintreten plant jetzt können wir
entweder sagen wir machen ihren
kompliment wir sagen etwas kluges sagen
hat das witzige ist oder wir umarmen sie
ich würde sagen wie umarmen sie mal
direkt die luxair bieri
ihr müsst wissen aufgrund des titels und
weil es am anfang auch schon gesagt habe
das ist eigentlich schon meine freundin
ich wir simulieren nur gerade so ein
date fürs video
[Musik]
glaubt ihr nicht ihr glaubt nicht dass
meine freundin ist deswegen sage ich
dich küssen sie mal direkt und sie sagt
auch motto rot vor
ich liebe dich ich dachte sich schmeißt
mich ist meine freunde und ich kann mich
nicht rausschmeißen ihr wunderjahr
zusammen ich mache jetzt mal ein
bisschen musik an und machen einmal
hier liefert user schreibt marcus h
[Musik]
das geht jetzt schon ein bisschen zu
weit
ich mach mal miteinander ruhm und wir
gehen jetzt mal ich will jetzt einfach
mal schere stein papier mit ihr ich will
einfach mal den guten alten stein europe
scee shows what we take barbecue
machen um ein bisschen wein dann machen
wir jetzt mal den tenniscourt ich google
jetzt nicht was die lösung ist weil
google das hilft mir richtig weiter für
dieses quiz ihr tatsächlich es ist auf
jeden fall oder b aber ich würde echt
tendenziell ich sag mal 66 oder dieses
paradies take off stage ja mal ein
bisschen schwimmen
ein bisschen hier letzter macho was ist
denn das hier vorne sollten wir ein
bisschen im heads-up bisschen wein einem
jahrhundert feeling that may be made by
that calls for tax also sie ist ja schon
meine freunde und das war wir haben
jetzt nur simuliert ich sage jetzt etwas
kluge ist dann küss ich sie mache ich
jetzt einfach mal finger der turn und
zement
ich bin so scheiße man erst mal schön
umarmen saddam direkt küssen so da
machen wir jetzt mal als widget engine
soll jetzt hier habe ich verloren oder
was ist dann sage ich hier jetzt wieder
schön dass der krater kopernikus ist
damit sie denkt ich bin total klug ist
jetzt ein bisschen steak dann waren
jetzt hier
hier ein bisschen dann noch mal ein
bisschen bei daran ein bisschen tag
wir spielen jetzt mal spin de bordeaux
wir gehen jetzt mal rein und schauen uns
auf ich warte natürlich wieder im whole
way soll da machen wir jetzt mal got the
kitchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
entweder ich sage gute nacht oder ich
kürze gute nacht wieso kann ich nicht
einfach mal bei der penan ich sage jetzt
einfach mal weg gehen nach draußen um
irgendwo was essen zu gehen
[Musik]
erst mal ein bisschen tanzen naja ich
dancing ja ab jetzt ist das video +18
entweder boxen
ich meine wir sind ja auch zusammen
die lava die die ganze zeit sondern
scheiße und jetzt wenigstens sind wir
schon mal weg bei ihr sind jetzt im
livingroom trinkt man auch ein bisschen
wein dance immer noch diesmal zulässt
dann mache ich mal tippen
da machen wir mal wird langsamer als
freunde
warum kann ich die müssen